all right brian hey brian uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
uh tycoon northeast philadelphia
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad
yeah both had mom and dad
um father was alcoholic um he ran with a
biker gang
uh one percent crew um not gonna name
their names but um
they ran a
better portion of the meth trade through
uh throughout the bucks county lower
southeast end of pennsylvania
um
my life was a party every night just
about you know
um
all my cousins
um
parents affiliates friends you know we
were like our own little crew
um we did what we wanted we had no rules
half the time you know our parents were
wasted
um
started doing drugs at a young age
just it just was the normal
normal life for us you know
just like to have fun just like you know
just like to be free and
and uh just never really had much
um
guidance yeah no guidance really yeah
yeah
tell me about your mom
um my mom she's an angel you know she um
she took a brunt of the lot
um
that's why i kind of take more towards
towards women towards looking out for
him because you know the male figures in
my life that turned out to be a lot of i
seem to be more of the
kind of scumbag where uh
you know my mom was always there for me
where uh you know i've never had that
with my father or any anybody else any
other male figures so i always took my
mom as as my angel
um
she was taken
taken away from me um
around the age of six six years old they
took took me away from my parents the
state and uh why did that happen
um
there was a
blues
um it's called bucks county blues
society they would have these picnics
that were basically big biker gatherings
and
a rival crew came
and
there was a
shootout
involving um
my
my family my father being one
um
they saw
me like the best kids there during when
it went on and uh
children's youth
services came in and they took
took me away from my parents
who raised you then
uh my grandparents
which were great people
but still a little guidance
they were older
i was little
by that age too rowdy for them you know
it was hard for me
for them to control me
at their age
so i've still pretty much lived that
that carefree life i um i found a love
relating to punk rock music
and um
linked up with uh a crew out of
philadelphia punk rock kids and
most of them that's where i was
introduced to heroin
and a lot of other harder drugs and
stuff that continued on through my life
i loved chaos i loved violence i loved
the adrenaline
um
so i was also a tagger i still am a
graffiti writer
just about getting them all about being
getting above the law and just
you know
um
just living a life on my terms nobody
else's you think you get that from your
dad
yeah i think so yeah
yeah i think so do you think that's
learned behavior or do you think it it's
just in your dna
um
it's hard to say because you know it's
as i got
i got a sister and uh two other brothers
one other brother he's uh he did good
he's a school english teacher made it in
life i got uh another brother a younger
brother he was down here with me
on the streets
um we both were both absconding
and they grew up in the same environment
as you
not totally they might make my dad kind
of kind of calm down after my sister was
born my sister's five years younger than
me
so me and my brother took the uh the
brunt of
the biker life the party how about your
brother that's the teacher
yeah he he was he's older than me he
but he was uh
he used to get picked on a lot and he
never he always felt like he didn't
belong and as soon as he his goals were
to get through school and get to college
and get away as far as he as possible
and um his way
of
getting through life was always had his
his face in a book you know
always and would just escape that way
it's interesting how different
personalities
cope with
certain pressures
yeah certain situations like he um ran
more towards the academic end and
found his his escape through uh
through reading books where i ran
towards it you know i i lived it up how
far did you in school
um
i made through
well
two years of 10th grade i was locked up
i was
going back um once i got my parents got
uh parental rights
of me again i ended up getting booked
for um
two arson charges and a few
a few other little [ __ ] charges that
went along with it
and uh
that got me into this my
me into the system um
i was about 14 then
so um
i was locked up most of my teenage years
through through school
when i went back to school
none of my work was submitted so i had
to repeat 10th grade
um at my home school
which i did
and then um
same thing again you know
i'm back up up
you know another youth forestry camp or
uh did some time at a braxton street
and uh came back none of my work was
coming back to my home school
and um
same thing and i said [ __ ] it i said you
know what i'm done with this i'm not
repeating 10th grade again i'm bound i'm
done i'm done
i was over past it was past the age of
18 i was on juvenile probation until i
was 20 years old
um
which is you know
pretty abnormal you know usually you're
on there 18 you're you're supposed to be
cut off but for some reason i was on
there till i was 20.
and uh just from various charges and
trouble i kept on getting into as a
youth um
yeah so
you've been homeless for for how long
um
i was out here for seven years this has
been my seventh year out here in la
um back in philadelphia
i wasn't i didn't wanna do two i was
homeless but i i had friends and i had
people that i knew so i was more or less
like couch surfed and
i had uh people that i can rely on like
rely on places to stay
um
philadelphia about around that time i
lost all my friends
for just about the heroine back there
was killing everybody
um
i got booked on uh some more i had a
bunch of retail thefts
that i got charged with and um they're
building more cases against me
so my mom thought it was best
to get me out of there and i had an
opportunity to come out here for rehab
and
try to change my life around but that
only lasted maybe a month
and then i was back out running on the
streets
this is where i feel comfortable you
know
when i'm
why would you say you feel comfortable
living on the streets
um
i just i i feel uncomfortable i feel on
edge a lot of anxiety when i'm
around what i say
normal people
you know i just don't feel like i fit
into the realms of
society
um i've tried that route i've
i've had a domesticated
course of time where i was with a girl
for a number for a few years and even
put a ring on her finger and
um
it wasn't long until i got her hooked on
heroin and her parents found out and
they cut the wedding
off and um
two weeks later my grandmother died
so uh that was a rough year and that was
that was a year i really went downhill
and i just didn't give a [ __ ] i just was
i was trying to kill myself but i
couldn't kill myself because
you know
by the time i had enough drugs in my
pocket
to do it
i wouldn't want to kill myself anymore
because i had a pocket full of drugs
you know
so um
where do you stay today you're in a tent
no i'm i'm i'm a nomad
wing at night by night yeah pretty much
how do you support yourself
um boosting
mainly
um
cars
um retail
um wherever i see an
opportunity
you know
i go for it what is what is that way of
supporting yourself
how does it affect you emotionally
do you feel any guilt or shame over
uh i'm kind of immoral about it because
it's it's one of the things where you
know
growing up with my grandparents that's
one thing they
they
you know
um raised me with faith
in god you know so you know i mean i had
morals and i knew right from wrong
but it's one of those things where it's
a survival situation in my book you know
how i look at it as it's it's either
like it's either either die or you know
starts
and and if it comes to the point where
i'm i'm starving i'm gonna go and steal
to eat and you know whatever i need
i'm going to go and get it i i can't
hold a sign i can't beg i can't ask for
i'm just was never me
um
if i'm going to get it i'm going to take
it you know i'm not going to rely on
somebody else
to hand it to me
so living on the streets is it's rough
at times right
yeah it can be um
i usually roll with a crew you know but
um
recently the crew's kind of broken up
where it hasn't been a lot of us i've
been alone i've been by myself a lot
lately
so uh the first time in
this year especially i felt
i felt vulnerable you know multiple
times out here
what kind of stuff happens to you
out here
um
i get robbed gunpoint you know
um jumped you know beat down
uh numerous times i got a lot of
problems in certain neighborhoods
um
certain neighborhoods i tend to avoid
you know
some nights i'll be sleeping and
one night
this guy was was he he didn't know i was
right above him and i was in this little
spot and i saw him rob seven people at
one point you know
had him find me up there who knows what
the [ __ ] we would have done you know i
mean
um
you showed me you just got shot recently
too
yes got shot two nights ago i still got
the bull within me
and uh the infection's starting i'm
starting to feel the infection run
through my body right now
so i gotta get to the hospital and get
that pulled out
um
yeah i'd say one of the things that you
you always got to carry a knife or a
weapon on you you know you never want to
have to use it but when it comes to them
times you you got to do what you got to
do it's you know
that way is a tough city it's not easy
out here
is it is it tougher here than philly
were you in kansas kensington in philly
yeah i was in kensington how did they
compare how does kid row and kenzie
didn't compare
i mean kensington kensington wasn't that
bad because he had a lot of the dealers
looking out for you because you know
like you you the dealers the the
customers were their their bread and
butter you know
um they had things a lot more organized
we're out here
it's not like that
you know um
the gangs are starting to notice that
the white boys
uh homeless white boys have a lot more
money on them than
you know than they thought
you know a lot of us have big habits so
a lot of us are out there boosting and
carrying lots of merch and lots of money
on us so we became targets
um just recently downtown there's been a
lot of racial tension between the whites
and the blacks
um we've been dealing with that
um
[Music]
some things i can't really get into that
that started that
but it's it's it's gonna get ugly it's
gonna get really ugly
and um
it's the only one thing to do is
just keep your head up and
be aware of your surroundings and just
be ready for whatever because anything
can happen at any time how old are you
i'm 39 39 do you have kids no kids four
students
you've been a love it sounds like yeah
i've been in love
um i do have two two nieces and nephews
that
i love dearly
um
the only reason why i am
trying to uh
stay together and put my life together
um
i'm working on a project a zine project
that's i'm right now that
is i'm trying to roll into other things
um
i have a meeting on the 15th out in new
york city with a prominent graffiti
writer
he's going to
headline my first issue
so i'm hoping to get that
going together
i've been into art my whole life that's
that was kind of my my escape
that my bags and all are all full of art
materials you know
that should get stolen left and right so
i'm back and stealing you know i mean
refilling that all the time once or
twice a week you have to be prolific
when everything is being stolen yeah
it's hard you know
um
that's why it's been taking me so much
time time to get this this [ __ ] rolling
so
um
it's getting there i got everything laid
out and uh pretty much i'm gonna be set
for january for the first issue release
and i'll have a
comfort zone and three issue comfort
zone to
three months of ahead that will be put
together also so
it'll give me some time
um i'm gonna spend a little bit of time
probably
a few weeks back east and then i'm gonna
come back out here
um just because i need a
few tools and stuff like that where
um
a friend of mine is gonna help me with
getting the layouts and getting
everything done is getting clean
a part of that
um
or no i've slowed down a lot
my i've slowed down a lot since since
i've gotten more serious into this
um
i don't know if i'll ever get
be
clean clean
um
i've tried it so many [ __ ] times i
mean i've been in the hospital
[ __ ] countless times i almost lost my
leg
you know due to abscesses and infections
i mean i've been in situations where
i've sat in tents with a cardboard piece
of cardboard baton off for [ __ ]
20 rats that were chewing on my legs you
know i mean like
if you think that's not the bottom
that's not going to get you to quit and
what the [ __ ] is you know
um
heroin is still your drug or have you
found the fentanyl yeah that's that's
what most heroin addicts are doing
though yeah fentanyl xanax
benzes um
but i cut it back like i said i used to
do about 100 to 120 a day worth of that
[ __ ] and i'm down to about
40 40 dollars both you know combined
and that's just to keep my head straight
enough where i can get this
get this work done because if not i have
my i would have my eyes closed all day
long you know yeah are you smoking it or
you're injecting
um a little bit of both
yeah a little bit of both what is the
difference for
um a fentanyl addict to be smoking it or
injecting it well if i if i inject it i
like to put some speed in there
and uh i like to do a
big shot like i like to do
like a half gram anywhere two and a half
to a four gram shot and uh that'll last
me i'll have to do that once the day now
that'll keep me good all the way for 24
hours
we're smoking it i'm smoking it
every hour i'm i'm smoking that
that pipe to to keep my high up you know
so um
i kind of like shooting it better
because i only have to do it at once but
i don't get it i'm not as productive
when i do it that way so that's why i
kind of cut back to smoking it for right
now
once i get back into the position where
things are going
and i can i feel i have some time
[Music]
where i can do that a little more often
than yeah i'm gonna
you know
still
get high you know
hopefully maybe that this
things really start rolling and things
start going good in the right direction
and i started getting some
advertisements and
some funding to roll that
ultimately i want to get into um
branding my myself and
branding my name
and
doing um
a bunch of things like a clothing line
and uh
design interior exterior design for um
commercial
i really don't want to do like
residential but more commercial design
um
would you consider yourself
self-destructive
yeah
that's that's that's one of the that's
one of the scary points like the
points of like where i i'm afraid to
succeed because it seems like once i do
succeed i kind of like to sort of blow
everything through everything out out of
water and just
you know go back to this life because
like i said i don't feel
comfortable
in in normal situations you know i mean
group of normal people and
you know um
the one thing i have going with this
with with the scene and as it would be
working with like-minded people with uh
with a lot of other graffiti writers and
artists because it's one person people i
do can relate with is artists
you know i was just at a party some
bougie gallery thing going and like
these guys are all like fancy
and i'm in there in my dirty clothes and
they accepted me for as an artist and
not as you know a homeless
drug addict you know what i mean
so like i i kind of felt
a piece of comfort there and like around
those type of people
so um
if i focus my work and
future work around like those type of
people i think i can make it you know
but i think that's the only shot i have
at it if not uh i'm probably gonna die
out here
and brian what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life most important lesson i've learned
uh
never get in your head too much you know
never never
get down on yourself
you know i suffer from depression but
there's always
somebody going through something a lot
worse and there's there's always going
to be there's always going to be a you
feel bad now but wait two weeks
you know there's going to be a worse
time down down the road
you know there's more problems than that
you realize that are gonna you're gonna
have to deal with
so i just try to stay optimistic as as
like most as most optimistic as i can in
this situation
whether it be shitty or not
i just know it can be worse it can be
better
it's going to be better
that's about it and don't get the fear
and you you know keep the fear out of
you just
fight on like a soldier basically
all right brian thank you so much for
sharing your story
no problem thanks for having me yeah
good luck in new york
thank you thank you
you